[Music]
please do it now that our bipartisan
bicameral negotiations on defense
spending and other priorities have
yielded a significant agreement no one
would suggest it is perfect but we
worked hard to find common ground and
stay focused on serving the American
people the budget deal doesn't have
everything Democrats want it doesn't
have everything Republicans want but it
has a great deal of what the American
people want I'm heartened that Congress
recognizes the sobering effect of
budgetary uncertainty on America's
military and on the men and women who
provided for our nation's defense it's
bringing our panel to talk about that
byron york chief political correspondent
of the Washington Examiner
maybe Stoddard associate editor at Real
Clear Politics and host of No Labels
radio on Sirius XM and Molly Hemingway
senior editor at The Federalist welcome
to all of you on this we think we may
have averted a shutdown Wednesday
biron we'll start with you so there's a
lot of money for defense for the
Republicans a lot of domestic money for
the Democrats what is this doing to the
budget and deficit though in the long
term well it makes the budget bigger and
the deficit bigger there's no doubt
about that I think I think what it shows
is that a lot of lawmakers Republican
and Democrats were just they don't want
another governor shutdown and they're
tired from just staggering from one
continuing resolution to another and you
know we'll have the government's going
to shutdown in three weeks and then in
two weeks after that and then again I
mean that's just no way to do it
Republicans have been wanting to get
more money for defense they're gonna get
a lot more money for defense Democrats
have been wanting more money for
domestic spending they're gonna get that
and the budget talks are gonna get mad I
mean
then they'll stage protests votes up
against this and then everybody will
make a deal well maybe I mean this is
something that Republicans have talked
about for decades so they don't like big
government and letting spending lots of
money but it sounds like that's what
they had to do to get this deal done
today
yeah the parties I like the parties
coming together I host No Labels radio
where this ends up we have no idea but
it is true the parties never agree on
fiscal discipline they agree on spending
more when they win that when it gets too
hot in the room they go okay let's just
throw money at it and walk out and
that's that is the makings of a deal the
supercommittee of 2011 was a joke it led
to the sequester now there's gonna be no
sequester no mandatory across-the-board
spending cuts because they can't agree
on where the budget is that the budget
should be trunk is going to be tough for
Republicans politically they want to
turn out there you know base of support
and this fall's midterm elections their
voters are happy about the tax reform
bill but it did affect the deficit they
are going to be looking at a two-year
period of time where they let the budget
bust even more and it is going to be
it's very frustrating to fiscal Hawks
they will be overruled and a deal will
be made but it is an issue sort of at
the grassroots level because it's what
they promised they would attend to and
it's not just those two years for two
years you get an extra 150 all right
billion but then that creates this new
spending level and so everything will be
based off of that baseline so you talked
about the tax cuts at 1.5 trillion over
ten years this is going to work out to
be the same exact thing so
bipartisanship is a very good way to
bust deficits and increase well I know
first of all real quick I know that you
think that Schumer actually came out
pretty good in this deal I think I mean
it's this type of spending is is serving
him well and also being able to get out
of an immigration deal at the same time
I think he understands the numbers are
very bad for Democrats with immigration
and he was able to avoid that get a
bunch of spending so good for him not
good for fiscal conservatives or people
who care about the fiscal health of the
country but for a lot of Republicans I
mean this president doesn't really care
about fiscal discipline all that much he
wanted to have this deal the White House
is gonna be okay with this deal the
president will
well a campaign for whatever candidates
it would help wherever he's welcome as
we approach November so there's really
nothing no problem with this and the big
the big thing as far as our recent
fights is there's no daca in it I mean
Donald Trump sees that as a victory and
a lot of Democrats and the leftist base
see that is a real loss because they've
given up leverage once more and by the
way it has a debt ceiling clause in this
which is going to get the debt ceiling
past November so nobody can use a debt
ceiling for leverage and this is just a
win for the White House well it's gotta
go to the house though now a B and there
are gonna be critics on the left and the
right who are unhappy about this package
right that's where they're gonna have to
work some more wondrous behind closed
doors because that's right
the house has a freedom caucus that is
supposed to stand up and object to this
on budgetary reasons and then you're
gonna have you know this roaring left
saying we didn't get an agreement on a
daca fix so we can't vote for anything
again I don't know I think that you can
probably see a situation where Donald
Trump gets on the phone and Ben's enough
ears and minds
among those fiscal Hawks in the freedom
caucus to get the numbers to where they
need to be and then they lose the
Liberal Democrats on the house side but
they get it through maybe that's an
optimistic scenario but that's where I
see the math going without playing out
today we saw Nancy Pelosi the house
Minority Leader take to the floor for
eight hours and just moments ago we saw
the picture of the shoes that she was
wearing if those are the shoes that she
was wearing regardless of where you are
on the positions that Nancy Pelosi holds
I gotta take my hat off to her she's
wearing those foreign chose stilettos
the entire time of this eight hours
that's some sacrifice well in just long
speeches in general are admirable it's
something you used to see a lot in the
Senate and see it in the house and
people have stopped talking through
issues you're advocating for their
belief so it's it is admirable to see
someone given eight was at eight hour
speech at the same time it does feed
into these problems that Democrats have
right now which is that they care more
about non-citizens than citizens and
they're willing to do a lot of work on
behalf of non-citizens without thinking
through the people who will actually be
eligible to vote for them in the those
folks to be eligible for Pelosi is that
a lot of her her base thinks this is
just show anyway she was part of this
deal she was part of the leadership that
came to this deal and they said oh it's
really nice that you go out and give an
eight-hour speech we're glad you're on
our side but you're just gonna you're
just going to agree to it when when
crunch time comes so this was really a
very very long virtue signaling from the
Minority Leader telling the you know key
constituent groups that she's on their
side even though they're about to just
put daca off to the side okay let's talk
about the new text that we're seeing
more of today put together by Senator
Ron Johnson some of these have been
released between again Peter struck and
Lisa page one of them comes to us on
September 2nd 2016 and says TPS for D
apparently making a we think talking
about talking points for D the director
Comey page says yes because POTUS wants
to know everything we're doing there was
some speculation that was about the
Hillary Clinton email investigation but
now there's talk that that was about the
Russia potential collusion investigation
a B but it's now raising more questions
and more criticism for these people who
were so intimately involved with both of
those investigations right but the Wall
Street Journal reported this afternoon
that they think from their reporting
they've concluded the senator Johnson is
incorrect and that this was a president
asking for intelligence on Russian
meddling because he was going to face
Putin in person in the coming days I I'm
you know I think Peter struck and Lisa
Paige if Heather everyone's made up
their minds about what they were doing
we still don't know the answer to the
question you know what the insurance
policy is they discussed in Andy's
office and that is the office of Andrew
McAfee since left the deputy FBI
director there's a lot of questions that
I have but I'm going to think I'm gonna
go with the Wall Street Journal
reporting on this until further notice
that is what's interesting about the
Wall Street Journal reporting initially
some people thought it had to do with
the old Hillary Clinton email
investigation learning that it's in fact
about the Trump Russia meddling election
is far more interesting what when was
Obama first briefed on the Trump
components of that investigation when
did he first learn about the dossier I
think a normal press corps would be very
interested in getting answers to that
and this is just again just a tiny part
of a much larger scandal that also had
news break about senators Grassley and
Senator senator Graham did a criminal
referral of Christopher Steele that
verifies a lot of what that Nunez memo
last week said that there was the use of
this unverified salacious dossier that
they didn't tell the court that this was
bought and paid for by Hillary Clinton
and the Democratic National Committee
and that they didn't corroborate this in
any meaningful sense so having that
corroboration not just from the house
but the Senate that there are problems
with our surveillance authorities is
also big news yeah why do you think that
that memo didn't get a lot of attention
yesterday when it came out because what
essentially Grassley had done is they
set this for a criminal referral back in
January but well what they'd essentially
asked the FBI to do is unredacted as
much as possible so that they could
release the memo now this is prepared by
different people a different body than
Devin Nunez and it does as Molly said
seemed to lay out many of these same
claims almost exactly as we saw in the
house memo yeah I think it didn't get as
much attention because a lot of people
certainly all Democrats and a lot of
people in the press had already
pronounced the house memo a dud so it's
all over this was as you write a
separate investigation coming to this
conclusion separately and certainly
people in the House committee are
frustrated today that this is not
getting more in tension because they do
feel it is corroboration for their
findings now you know on the dossier one
of the themes we have been seeing in
recent months on this dossier is that
we're learning every day that knowledge
of the dossier went up higher and
further around in the Obama
administration than we previously knew
it went up higher in the FBI went up
higher in the Justice Department just
recently a top Obama State Department
official said she knew about the dossier
in July which was which was really early
there'd only been one or two
installments of it at that point so the
idea of asking whether they were talking
to the president about that no in
September 2nd is not a crazy idea at all
well we'll see because something tells
me this is not the last batch of text
that we're going to see